we received an avalanche of feedback
after bobo lost over 5,000 twitter
follows this was this was now wednesday
yeah we left you he had lost over 5,000
Twitter followers right and then he
gained back 400 followers yeah I gotta
say this whole movement it's like
getting stung by a bunch of goons I
thought it was gonna go down faster cuz
the great Jimmy Kimmel while of he
announced it on his monologue I said
dude Evolvin did you I saw that but I
didn't hear it here it is with the
corona virus spreading Genesis reuniting
the unfollow Bobo movement raging and on
top of all that someone held up a
unfollow Bobo sign at the WWE event on
Sunday really now my guys did an
analysis 30% of Bobo's followers are
what they call BOTS and how did he get
BOTS Howard we're trying to figure out
back here we can't really figure out how
he got the bots we don't know 30% of
whatever he had well that's roughly I'd
say 15 BOTS and 5,000 people would you
say Gary hello are you talking to me
does he hear us I don't know he's the
woman 20 people are talking to me at
once well talk to me I'm the most
important tell them to get on mic and
talk what I doing what is it a [ __ ]
game of telephone I'm talking to you and
you're staring at I'm saying it's
probably about 15,000 of his followers
or BOTS that's correct now you don't
know what the [ __ ] how we got BOTS if
someone knows put them on the mic nobody
knows oh who are you talking to
well somebody was trying to tell me the
number of bots he has oh who is them
there's 50 people talking for one to
grab them and put them on Mike Howard
yeah the website you can put in anyone's
Twitter and it tells you how many BOTS
there are Bobo has an unusually high
amount fifteen point eight thousand how
could he get those ma'amed my guess is
if you have that many it doesn't cost
that much money to buy followers so you
know you know for a couple hundred bucks
could you buy powers at that never and
I'll take a lie detector that I never
bought one file that's so [ __ ]
douchey is that the Train and all those
that's the damn truth Howard yeah I just
on our website yeah they they can't say
for sure how bobo got the bots but they
find it very unlikely that he has that
many Bostic and he didn't pay for it so
they think he's paying for it no way
Jason are you lying to me Bobo
I'm not lying to talent I I would I
would be food to show forever I would
never ever pay for followers I never did
I learned all those follows people
follow me because they want to follow me
for the show that's it
Shirley what do you think you think
Bobo's lying right now there's a
unusually large number of bots on his
account which would make you believe
that they were purchased no way no way
and I also I also have this to inform
you of go ahead Bobo has contacted me
all weekend long and he came up with an
essay on why it's important that he have
followers so I'd like for him to read it
live I would like to hear spontaneous
off-the-cuff sheep in sheep's clothing
yeah
read it all right
why is it important for the fans to
follow me on Twitter I have to be
brutally honest
woo got I had a moment oh I can't say
truly probably would start again
alright this is going to be taking why
is it important for the fans to follow
me on Twitter I have to be brutally
honest that I had a moment to pause and
reflect for a moment of clarity what I
was about a moment of pause and we'll
fly fuh fuh-fuh how many times did he
use moment I didn't even file started
again started again we're gonna count
the moments all right why is it
important for the fans to follow me on
Twitter I had to be brutally honest that
I had a moment to pause and reflect for
a moment of clarity wow I am still
actually questioning myself as to why
it's important for me to have fans maybe
it's a purpose of being part of the
greatest radio show ever
I just feel like it's one big huge
family within star nation and I don't
want to feel left out so by having a
large fanbase and my mind keeps me more
connected to the show period period I
like when you say period like we don't
know that or did you make that little
dot pain hashtag that's his mic to see
right period why is it important for the
fans to follow me on Twitter it has
nothing to do with that Bobo in other
words the fans don't care it's important
for you to have because it's important
to you
mr. nation why so they follow me
sometimes they say things in my account
or you know I'll put things up and it
feels more of a substantial nation
family you know what I mean yeah in
other words you saying it feels to you
like there's more of a community when
people follow you so it's important for
you to have fans not for the fans to
follow you know it's important for me to
have it yeah but your title says it's
important to the fans to it you don't
know why you don't know why it's
important is the answer you don't know
why you wrote this can I be honest I
think you need another moment I'm still
a bit confused myself can you read the
confused part again we want to hear yeah
oh okay I am actually questioning myself
as to why it's important for me to have
fans
maybe it's the purpose of being part of
the greatest radio show ever
the whole point is to have followers and
he's not even sure why I used my bots
are confused
my sheep are confuse might be the
greatest document ever written